oh i thought that was you how does an
actor land two roles in the same film
they sneakily audition for two different
casting directors
today we're taking a look at actors who
pulled double duties in their films
which actors played not just two
different characters but two different
species
how about who played a very small often
overlooked role in one of their most
legendary films
let's take a look young actors out there
this is what you got to do
if you want to play in the big leagues
we all know him as deadpool
but what caught us off guard was
learning that reynolds was responsible
for another
very significant role as well if
juggernaut ever sounded familiar
it's because reynolds was pulling double
duty big cgi fight coming up
we can see that there is obviously a
huge difference between the two
characters physically
juggernaut is actually a combo of
reynolds voice the director david
leitch's face
and cgi creating the body what's more is
that this was totally unplanned
reynolds did the voiceover so the team
had a temporary audio track for the
character but
something about it stuck and it wound up
making the final cut
when it comes to asking who played the
winklevoss twins the answer is kind of
complicated
technically the twins tyler and cameron
were played by two different people
army hammer and josh pence however
looking at these shots from the film
it's obvious that the face of both twins
is definitely army hammer so what gives
director david fincher felt that hammer
looked more realistically like the twins
so he opted to have the editing team
create a digital map of hammer from the
neck up
this was then projected onto pence's
face for the final cut of the film
this is definitely one of the most
unusual ways that we've ever heard of
twins being captured for film
everybody cheated warwick davis as well
as the makeup and prosthetics team
really showed off their skills for harry
potter and the philosopher's stone
here we have professor flitwick and the
goblin bank teller
two different characters two different
species but played by just
one actor davis took on both roles and
brought the two unique characters to the
screen
as for makeup and prosthetics they
definitely had their work cut out for
them
check out the facial differences between
the two characters
they really managed to completely
disguise davis making him unrecognizable
in both roles
it's a team effort of course robin
williams became a disney staple as the
genie
none of us can forget that memorable
performance however he also played
various real-life characters with snappy
impersonations
remember this groucho marx how about
this carol channing
these are pretty obvious disguises since
well
he is a magical genie what isn't so
obvious is his other significant role
remember the peddler we briefly see the
beginning of the movie revealing the
genie's lamp and going on to tell the
story
of how the lamp changed the life of a
young man that peddler
is actually voiced by williams as well
perhaps you would like to hear the tale
like some others on this list though it
wasn't just williams who brought him to
life
bruce adler was actually the one
responsible for his singing voice
when he plays doctor strange cumberbatch
is extremely recognizable
which is why it was so surprising to
learn that he actually has
another role in the mcu as we can see
these two characters look completely
different on screen
while his body may not have been used
his voice was the one that brought the
character dormammu to life
you will never win since dormammu is a
cgi creation
it was up to cumberbatch to change his
voice enough so it wouldn't be
recognized
as well as making sure to animate the
epic character
eddie murphy became famous many years
ago for taking on multiple roles in his
films
it seems like each film got even more
wild than the one before it
his first multi-character movie was in
the 1988 film coming to america
so why was he so inclined to play these
four different characters
the inspiration actually came from peter
sellers who's also played multiple roles
in one project
the prosthetics and makeup team did
loads of work to transform murphy's face
entirely so he could play each of these
roles i did voices i was always a good
mimic
over 30 years later murphy took on each
role again for the 2021 movie
coming to america it's nice to see these
faces again
even if they are totally fabricated
that's why i'm a comedian
canadian actor alain chanwan found
success with his role as incubus in
suicide squad
a pretty stellar gig for any actor chen
wan can not only boast that role but the
fact that he actually had a second one
in the same film
we never noticed it before but he
actually appears as one of the
enchantresses eyes of the adversary as
well
so why did he have such a random bit
part turns out when auditions came
around
there were two casting directors
auditioning different roles and shanwan
doubled his chances by auditioning for
both without saying anything
clearly he was doing something right
they don't get much groovier than austin
powers
there was plenty of groove to go around
in the movie austin powers and gold
member
similar to eddie murphy mike myers gave
a tour to force performance appearing in
the film as
all four of these very different
characters i love
gold there is something familiar about
all these mischievous grins
with an impressive combination of
prosthetics makeup costumes and even
colored contacts
myers was totally disguised yeah
a little creepy the first time
mendelssohn had ever worn a prosthetic
mask for a role was when he played
scroll leader talos in captain marvel
since his face is totally disguised and
he plays an alien his taking on the role
of nick fury's human boss was easy
enough to pull off visually
mendelson definitely rose to the
challenge and did incredible accent work
bringing his authentic australian accent
to talos and doing an amazing american
accent for the boss
if you sit down and you listen to this i
assure you
it'll be worth your while night at the
museum secret of the tomb was actually
the most complicated work stiller has
ever had to do in a movie this was
mainly because he took on two characters
larry daly and la the caveman
one of the most difficult aspects was
shooting the scenes that were between
larry and la it is hard to do
stiller described the whole experience
as very surreal
where i am you're in a museum they're
actually under it
if you thought you were seeing double
amy adams in this night at the museum
film
you would be right she of course played
tess
but she also took on the role of the
famed historical pilot amelia earhart
as we can see wigs wardrobe glasses
and makeup were major contributors to
the transformation
she really does look similar to the real
earhart
jason isaacs definitely proved his
excellent range when he took on both the
role of mr darling
and captain hook he's back the reason
for the double casting was actually a
nod to how the stage production is
traditionally done
in a theater the two roles are generally
played by just one actor
these two have totally different looks
making them quite difficult to tell
apart
one of dick van dyke's most legendary
performances was definitely as burton
mary poppins
however he also makes a total
transformation when he appears as a much
older bank teller mr
dawes senior his energetic performance
is unforgettable
but he also makes a really strong impact
as the teller with his white-haired wigs
some fake eyebrows and this skillfully
done makeup
what's unique about this case is that
van dyke actually paid
walt disney four thousand dollars to let
him play both parts because disney had
originally said he wouldn't pay for it
i'm sorry where was i kate hudson's
acting chops were key in making the film
alex and emma
as if it weren't enough that she was
playing one of the title characters
she played a wild range bringing an
extra four characters to life
she was actually playing parts that she
was helping to write in the world of the
movie
it's all pretty meta i heard someone go
wow hudson had loads of fun doing this
unique project as it offered such an
exciting challenge to tackle
she dazzled as glinda and oz the great
and powerful
but she also played a much less glam
character
we're talking about this kansas farm
girl annie
while working on two roles in the same
film could be stressful
william's called working on the movie a
dream on a couple of levels
not a bad review can you understand
i do do you we're amazed
just thinking about how skilled the
actors have to be in order to play such
different roles in the same project
especially playing opposite themselves
we also have to give credit to the
makeup
hair and prosthetic departments because
they definitely had their work cut out
for them and
totally fooled us with some of these
transformations which multi-character
role surprised you most